good morning John like an absolute
accidental mutant of a KitKat this video
comes to you in three parts part number
one when you get food poisoning as I did
last night it's important to recognize
that you don't necessarily know where
you got the food poisoning this is
because many things deliver the same
symptoms and are foodborne pathogens can
have vastly different onset time E coli
and camphorobacter they could take like
two to five days to get you whereas
staff that might just take 15 minutes
salmonella can be anywhere from six
hours to six days just because you ate
something and then got sick doesn't mean
the thing you ate got you sick unless
you ate that thing with a bunch of other
people and they also got sick which is
what happened to me so I know exactly
what it was but I just think that's an
interesting thing to know part two I
have decided to not use Twitter between
now and January so that I can sort of
have this break which is supposed to be
a holiday anyway and also be taking a
break from whatever it is that Twitter
is because it's not like I don't have a
lot of stuff I'd like to do during that
break that's going to be fun and
productive that won't be Twitter however
that does not mean that I have stopped
having the desire to tweet or the ideas
to tweet so I'd like to read to you some
of the things I would have tweeted if I
had been on Twitter is bubble water
addictive this is an interesting
question I like some scientists to tell
me what if we started an instant [ __ ]
company like the Vietnamese noodles and
called it Unforgettable that's probably
for the best if we want to save the
world we need ways to make Rich Bros
feel powerful without giving them any
actual power probably again for the best
like that's not a Nuance to take because
the best Tweets are the worst ones right
we all know this it's not good to be
good at something bad this is real this
was about me so that sounds judgmental
but no it was it was specifically about
me feeling like I'm good at tweeting and
that that doesn't mean that I should do
it don't go around pronouncing medieval
like medieval you'll never learn how to
spell it that way you gotta say medieval
and like medieval it's got to be better
right because medieval makes it sound
like it's the middle of evil I don't
think that was what it was or what we
intended for it to mean I've also got
got in here don't ever rag on someone
for their music tastes music is such a
glorious part of the human experience
and literally no good can come from
making it worse for someone I feel like
that one's pretty good part number three
John it's time for the nerdfighteria
census yes I have been sitting in my bed
all morning writing questions and
modifying questions and adding new
social networks that didn't exist a year
ago you don't know what this is every
year since 2013 we've put out a survey
to our audience so that we can better
understand you what you're up to what
you want from us what you'd like to do
what's are you struggling with what
you're optimistic about it very much
informs the decisions that we make it
helps us understand this community
better it's one of my favorite parts of
the year so there's a link in the
description you can click on it and go
with all the census now I have
intentionally made this video short so
that you have some extra time I'm going
to give back to you so that you can give
it back to me when you fill out the
census John I'm gonna go lie back down
I'll see you on Tuesday